Good morning, folks. How are you today?
Right now, let's bring to the stage Dr.
Wallach.
Uh, thank you very much.
Many of you have heard my lectures
recently, and some of you haven't. So,
some of this some of it, not all of it,
will be old hat to you, but for many of
you it'll be new. Our goal, of course,
is to have everybody die after 120. I
don't care if it's 150 or 200, whatever
it is. We have the capacity, we have the
knowledge to get you well beyond 100, no
doubt about it. Everybody when they die
past 120 should only have two pieces of
paper in your health chart, a birth
certificate and a death certificate. If
you have a 4-in thick health chart full
of all these surgeries and all these
diseases, your doctor has failed you,
the system has failed you.
And we want to be known as the Home
Depot of health. We want people when
they think of health, well, I'm not
going to run to the doctor. I I I I can
do this myself. Just like when you're
going to lay tile in your house, does
everybody call a contractor now? No,
they say, I'm going to run to Home Depot
and buy some tile there. And so, we have
the capacity. Just quickly, the
interesting thing of this, which is a
September 2000 issue of Scientific
American cover article, almost the
entire issue is devoted to human aging
and 100-year-olds. There were lectures
by different doctors, there were
lectures by nurses or articles by
doctors and nurses. There are articles
by nutritionists and dieticians,
geneticists, gerontologists, and they
all had different agendas on how to live
past 100, but there was a common thread
amongst all their articles. The common
thread was that everybody who lived to
be 100 were mean, feisty, rebellious
patients who did not listen to their
doctors' instructions.
They couldn't figure it out. The people
who listened to their doctors'
instructions to the letter didn't make
it. They had these 4-in thick health
charts, the ones who listened to their
doctors.
And you're going to find out why in just
a second.
Again, all the experts in genetics and
gerontology tell us that we have the
capacity, very clearly, to live to be
100. It's not like it's a secret.
Everybody agrees on that. It's not a
mystery, it's not a fable we're coming
up with that you can live to be well
beyond 100. People do it all the time.
How many Raise your hand if you've ever
made a dish from a recipe, a cookbook, a
magazine, card collection? I mean, we've
all done that. I mean, us guys, you
know, they don't raise their hands, but
yeah, they love to cook. Make pancakes,
make Pillsbury Doughboy muffins, you
know. And the reason why they put
pictures in cookbooks and things like
that is so that you know where you're
going. If I follow this recipe directly,
and I use the flour they recommend, I
use the type of sugar they recommend,
and use the right type of shortening
they recommend, my fruitcake can look
like that. My asparagus lemon dish can
look like that. My cranberry stuffed
pork loin roast is going to look like
that. Okay, that's why they put the
pictures there. The same thing is true
when it comes to health care. We've been
using the same recipe, if you will, for
our health care in the industrialized
nations for over 300 years. And so, we
can predict what the recipe outcome is
going to be. We can predict that
already. We know what a 25-year-old
looks like, we know what a 50-year-old
looks like, we know what a 75-year-old
looks like, and a 100-year-old, and so
forth. And so, you can kind of look down
the line, and if you follow your
doctor's instructions, you eat the way
everybody's eating, you know what you're
going to look like. Well, this is a
pretty typical 85-year-old American.
You're in a nursing home, you have
Alzheimer's disease, you have macular
degeneration, you've had cataract
operations, you're deaf, your teeth are
gone cuz you had periodontal disease,
which is osteoporosis of the face and
jaw. Your thyroid's been removed for
many reasons, so you're on drugs. You've
had your shoulders replaced, you've had
carpal tunnel surgeries, you've had your
finger joints replaced, you've had
multiple back surgeries, you've had
angiograms, angioplasties, stents have
been inserted in your coronary arteries,
you've had quadruple bypass, you've had
a heart transplant, you've had maybe one
lower entire lung removed for many
different things, including lung cancer,
which is the most common cause of cancer
in both men and women, regardless if you
smoke or not. 95% of the people who get
lung cancer don't smoke, never did
smoke. Cuz a lot of good church-going
Christians that never smoked never been
in a room with anybody who smoked got
lung cancer. That's cuz they're frying
the fish after church and inhaling all
those free radicals coming out of that
frying oil. And then, you can have your
stomach banded and bypassed to lose
weight, or maybe you had ulcers and had
your stomach removed. You've had kidneys
removed, you've had kidney stone
operations, you've had gallbladders
removed, your colon removed for polyps
and cancer. Women have had hysterectomy,
and men have had their prostate gland
removed. And by the way, the newest
information on the PSA, how many of you
have heard of the PSA test, ladies and
gentlemen, you know, for prostate
activity? Since 1987 to now, when they
actually done the survey, when they
removed prostates cuz they thought it
was cancer by actual biopsy, only 2%
were actually cancers. 98% false alarm.
98% is a false alarm. No man, I
shouldn't say that, but no man who's
done everything right has ever died from
prostate cancer. You can die at 80 and
have prostate cancer, but the prostate
cancer didn't kill you. Nobody should
ever die of prostate cancer. They've had
hip replacements, knee replacements,
feet have been amputated because they
had diabetes. They're on 25 different
medications for lowering cholesterol,
for dealing with blood pressure, for
thyroid, for diabetes, and many a pain,
and so forth. And if you follow the
doctor's instructions, this is where
you're going. This is where you're going
to wind up.
I mean, I'm excited. This is the recipe
I want. I'm going to follow this recipe.
And uh,
I'm not too excited about that one.
Maybe we have to get rich to live a long
time. Well, there's never been a
billionaire who's ever lived to be 100.
Think about it. Now, if money were
important to living to be 100, you'd
think that billionaires would live to be
100. There's never been a single one.
This is just from a couple of months ago
out of Forbes magazine. They said the
average lifespan for billionaires is 78.
The youngest one to die last year was 58
years old. He was the richest man in the
United States. He was the heir to the
Walmart empire. His daddy, old Sam
Walton, when he died left his entire
empire to this guy, and he died at 58.
The richest man in America died at 58.
You see, money didn't help him at all,
did it?
I know, it's intelligence. That's it. We
got to get more degrees in school.
That'll do it. There's never been a
Nobel Prize winner who's ever lived to
be 100. Linus Pauling came close. The
only guy who ever had two unshared Nobel
Prizes, got to be smart, died of
prostate cancer. You don't have to do
that, right? Died of prostate cancer at
94. So, there's never been a billionaire
who's lived to be 100, there's never
been a Nobel Prize winner who's lived to
be 100.
Why didn't I think of it before? It's
fitness. That's what it is. Everybody
says doctors say that fitness is good
for you, got to exercise. Don't worry
about supplementing because you get
everything you need from your food, but
just exercise. With the exception of two
black gentlemen from the old Negro
Baseball League days in the 1920s and
'30s, there's never been a professional
athlete ever lived to be 100. Now, if
fitness is important, you'd think a
significant number of professional
athletes would be living to be 100 cuz
not only do this fitness thing, but they
also have lots of money. So, money and
fitness combined doesn't save athletes.
But I love this title, Heart attack
claims another fitness guru. The average
lifespan for professional athletes is
62. I want to go there. So, what is it?
What is it? How do people live to be
100? So, we know it's not money, we know
it's not intelligence, it's not fitness.
So, how do people live to be 100? Again,
we can extrapolate information from
animals. We've
in the last 75 years tripled the
lifespans of animals. Pet animals,
laboratory animals, farm animals, we
tripled the lifespans. Do we do that
with wonder drugs? No. Do we do that
with genetically engineered proteins,
stem cells? Do we do that with heart
transplants? No. We did it just by
tinkering with the vitamins and minerals
in the essential fatty acids and amino
acids in their little food. Human beings
need 90 essential nutrients, you all
know that. We need 16 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12 essential amino acids,
three essential fatty acids, and
fortunately for us, our food plants, our
grains, vegetables, fruits, and nuts can
take carbon dioxide from the air, use
the sun's energy in a process known as
photosynthesis to manufacture carbon
compounds, wood, cellulose, starch,
sugar, vitamins, amino acids, fatty
acids. Yeah, plants can do all that, but
you'll notice that plants cannot
manufacture minerals. Plants cannot
manufacture minerals. And 2/3 of the 90
essential nutrients are minerals. That's
why we like to focus on minerals because
even a blind hog can get an acorn
sometimes, as my daddy used to say,
which means that even if you're eating a
cheeseburger with lettuce and tomatoes
and onions on it for breakfast, lunch,
and dinner, you can get some vitamins.
You're going to get some vitamin C and
beta carotene and folic acid from the
lettuce and tomatoes and onions. You're
going to get some omega-3 essential
fatty acids from the onions and the
little sesame seeds on the top of the
bun. You're going to get some B vitamin
from the vitamin B-enriched white flour
in the bun. You're going to get some
amino acids from the cheese, if it's
real cheese, and the meat. You might get
some calcium, if it's real cheese, on
the sandwich, but that's it. But you
could live to be 18 to 20 years of age,
you might even be able to have babies
and be fertile, you know, until 18 20
years of age. But if all you're living
on is hamburgers or cheeseburgers with
lettuce and tomatoes and onions on it
breakfast, lunch, and dinner, you're in
trouble because plants cannot
manufacture minerals. And most of our
degenerative diseases, most of the
things that kill us and worry us as we
live are mineral deficiency diseases.
Plants only need nine minerals to be
happy, we need 60. Plants can do very
well on three elements, NPK, nitrogen,
phosphorus, potassium. Farmers cannot
afford to put in all 60 essential
minerals. That's why they give animals
pellets to make up that difference. They
give them the pellets with all the
nutrients in it to make up the
difference cuz they don't know how many
minerals are in that pasture. They could
analyze it, but are they going to put 60
minerals in this pasture, this 10-acre
pasture for these cows? No. So, it's
cheaper just to give the cow the pellets
cuz they don't know how many minerals
are in that hay or in that pasture.
The longest-lived people in the
industrialized nations, the ones that
have the highest average of longevity,
are the Okinawans, and they live to be
85 on the average, and we live somewhere
around 70, 72 on the average in America.
And you go to Okinawa, it's 161 islands.
Their soil is nothing but red sandy
clay, much like the state of Georgia.
There's a little bit of extra iron in
there, but that wouldn't explain their
15 years living longer than us. And so,
Blake Graham and I went there, spent
almost a week, and we spent the first
couple of days at the Department of
Agriculture studying the soil and soil
chemistry and plant chemistry there in
Okinawa. We didn't find out anything
really unique. And then, we talked to
the old people. We talked about 15 of
them, half of them were men, seven of
them were men, eight were women. These
were all 100-plus year olds.
And we only had to ask one question
because this is a 25-year study, 25-year
study in the Okinawans. It was a
identical twin doctors. One got a
medical degree from Harvard, the other
got his PhD in pharmacy, and they spent
25 years there trying to figure out why
the Okinawans live so long. They counted
how many steps they took, how many times
a day they took a pee, what the volume
of their pee was, how many hours they
slept, how many calories they took in.
At the end of the 25 years, they said,
"We don't know."
"I don't know." And so, we weren't going
to re-ask these questions. We only ask
them one question. We only ask them one
question. We got each one individually
into a room so they wouldn't contaminate
the others with their answers. We didn't
want them thinking about the question.
We only want them to hear the question,
give the answer. So, the question was,
"What did you do with your wood ashes
and your rice straw ashes from your
heating and cooking from the previous
day?" And the men said, "We don't know.
You know, we're out there doing the
samurai thing with the swords and doing
the karate stuff, and we don't know."
But the women, every one of them gave
the same story. "Oh, we took the wood
ashes and the rice straw ashes and put
them in the garden as our grandmothers
and our mothers taught us to do as a
fertilizer. We mixed it in the noodle
dough and the rice because it gave it a
nicer taste and color. It turned it
yellow instead of white. And then,
thirdly, we cut our salt with it. 10
parts wood ashes and rice straw ashes
with one part salt cuz salt was very
expensive, and so they would cut it just
like a drug dealer cuts expensive
cocaine with flour so they would last
longer. So, they got plant minerals in
three different ways as fertilizer in
the garden, culinary ashes mixed in
their noodles and rice, and also by
cutting their salt with it. And wood
ashes and rice straw ashes are the plant
minerals that are left when you burn
away the carbon in the fuel. And people
have been using plant minerals as a
supplement since before written history.
We know this from the Neanderthals. They
were the first people to consciously
bury their loved ones when they died,
and they always put little pots of wood
ashes with them. They didn't ever figure
out why. Well, well, wood ashes are
plant minerals. They make you live
longer. What a concept. Make you
healthier. And then, they said one thing
I didn't know. They said, "And lastly,
an ash merchant came by every morning."
An ash merchant. Now, what does that
tell you? An ash merchant came by every
morning and would buy our excess wood
ashes and our excess rice straw ashes,
and they would sell these ashes to
farmers who had fields that were much
larger than their personal production of
ash could fertilize. It was an industry
cuz they knew it was important for
fertilization of that field. The first
patent in 1790, the first US patent, US
patent number one, was how to make white
wood ashes for export. They were burning
tens of thousands of acre of forest.
They just set those forests on fire and
collect the wood ashes and ship them to
England. That's because England had
burned every tree on the British Isles.
They were forced to go to coal, which
they hated cuz of the smoke and all that
kind of stuff. And because they burned
every tree, they were forced to use coal
as a fuel. But after the first 2 years
of mining coal, the mines flooded with
water, and the king formed what he
called the Royal Society to find a way
to pump the water out of the mines, and
they came up with a steam engine to pump
the water out of the mines, and that
started the Industrial Revolution
because they'd burned every tree. And
so, they were using the wood ashes from
America for their food and their garden
fertilizer and cutting their salt with
it. And all this information is in the
book Hell's Kitchen in a lot of detail.
Now, here's a little different recipe
for those of you who are sports fans.
May 2001, Harold Stilson from Deerfield
Beach, Florida, hits a hole-in-one on
his 101st birthday. Went out to play
golf on his 101st birthday, hits a
hole-in-one 108-yard par-3 hole. I mean,
Tiger Woods hasn't hit a hole-in-one in
I don't know how long. This was his
sixth This was his sixth one. You have
to have good enough vision to see that
stick holding up the flag at 108 yards.
You got to have a good grip on the club,
good eye-hand coordination to hit that
little banty chicken egg-size ball in a
teacup-size hole 108 yards away in one
whack. Wouldn't you rather have that
lifestyle than being in a nursing home
at age 85?
And you know he doesn't have Alzheimer's
disease cuz he's color coordinated.
How many of you remember Art Linkletter?
Okay, most of you are old enough to
remember him. Uh he wanted to live to be
100, and he was moved to want to live to
be 100 by reading a Pulitzer
Prize-winning novel by the title Lost
Horizon. Many of you won't remember that
title, but the author, James Hilton, the
one who won the Pulitzer Prize for
writing that novel, coined a term in
that book Lost Horizon called
Shangri-La. How many of you heard of the
term Shangri-La? Sure, everybody
remembers that one. It was a mythical
place you could live to be 2 300 years
of age if you followed their lifestyle,
very clean-cut lifestyle. Everybody had
their own little garden they put wood
ashes in, and they did all kinds of
other stuff as you're going to see in a
minute. And this novel was actually
written about real people called the
Hunzas who live in what's now northern
Pakistan. They were so famous for health
and longevity. They were the
longest-lived and the healthiest people
on Earth, and so even the king of
England sent his personal physician, one
Sir Robert McCarrison, to go there for 4
years. Went there for 4 years to study
how they lived so long and take the
information back to the king. And Robert
McCarrison was such a scientist, he
brought 4,000 white rats with him, and
he set up 1,000 rats on the Hunza diet,
1,000 rats on the New Delhi diet, and
1,000 rats on the English diet. Well,
during that 4 years, the English rats
died of the most horrible diseases,
became cannibals, and ate each other.
And the New Delhi rats lived a little
bit longer, but they didn't serve much
any better. They They had all diabetes
and high blood pressure and all that,
and died of liver cancer. But the Hunza
rats, they had to kill them at the end
of the 4 years. It's time to leave. None
of them died. None of It was wonderful.
So, he came back, and he said, "King, he
says, I don't know what it is, but it
has something to do with the diet." He
told the king about the experiment he'd
run, and so he says, "Here's a list of
everything the Hunzas eat." And the king
ate exactly as the Hunzas ate, and the
king died at 72. Well, Art Linkletter
hired an eye doctor by the name of Allen
Banik to go to Hunza and find out what
their secret was. Allen Banik was an eye
doctor, but he was also an amateur
farmer, and he didn't know exactly what
he was looking for, but he went He wrote
down everything. How they tied their
turban, how many steps they took each
day, how much they slept, how much water
they drank, how much of the volume of
their pee, how many times they went to
the number two. And he said, "I don't
know, but Art, here's all the
information. Pick what you want." Of
course, Allen Banik stayed, and Art
Linkletter just celebrated his 94th
birthday on Larry King a couple months
ago. Anyway, to make a long story short,
there's two things in this book that
jump out at you. Number one, they farm
at 19,500-ft
elevation. Their growing season is only
45 days.
Now, the wheat and the corn and the rice
we use, the growing season is 110 to 140
days. Can you grow those crops with a
45-day growing season? Nah. And so,
their total carbohydrate intake, because
they couldn't grow rice and wheat as we
know it and corn and that sort of stuff,
squash and things, their sum total of
their carbohydrate intake was a little
chapati bread the size of a silver
dollar pancake, one per person per day.
That was it. The rest of their diet
consisted of goat meat, lamb, mutton,
chickens, eggs, cheese, butter, maybe
some tomatoes and some green peppers and
onions and the garlic.
And so, it was a very low-carbohydrate,
very high-animal-fat, very
high-animal-protein diet. We know from
animal experiments that when you have a
low-carbohydrate diet, you can double
and triple lifespans of animals if you
give them all the nutrients. It's called
undernutrition without malnutrition. You
have to triple the vitamins and minerals
and cut the carbohydrate intake by 2/3,
and you'll triple their lifespan. Cut
the carbohydrate intake, triple the
vitamins and minerals, and we can triple
their lifespans. It's that easy. And
number two, he noted in this book very
clearly that they took their wood ashes
every morning and mixed it in their
garden. They cut their food with it and
their salt with it. They put it in their
food as culinary ashes and cut their
salt with it. Kind of like the
Okinawans. Isn't that amazing?
This is a beautiful story. It really
gives you some insight. Mel and I were
changing planes in Houston, Texas, in
July of 2004, and there was this
wonderful article in the Houston
Chronicle. It was about the discovery of
natural gas in Bolivia, a country in
South America. They were arguing who was
going to get the money, the indigenous
people, you know, the Native Americans,
so to speak, or the Native South
Americans, or the government. They were
arguing about this. But the most
important thing of this article to me
was this picture and the little legend
underneath this picture. It said, "Bruno
Paso, one of Bolivia's indigenous Aymara
Indians, holds a bowl of llama manure
he's using to feed his cooking fire."
Does that look like a GE kitchen,
ladies? No, it's a little 1-ft by 2-ft
cast iron stove. Look at all the soot on
the walls. He needs spring cleaning bad.
You know it's cold in there. If you've
ever been in a cabin with a fireplace,
your front end is cooking and your back
end is cold. He's got three shirts, a
sweatshirt, a parka. His ear flaps are
down in his house.
And he's feeding his fire. His fuel is
animal manure. Did Americans ever use
animal manure as fuel? Absolutely.
Buffalo chips, you think they came to
Vegas to get buffalo chips?
There's no trees on the prairie, so they
used horse manure, and they sent the
kids out with buckets to get all the
road apples and stuff like that, you
know? And so, we burned animal manure as
fuel, bundles of grass, trees, wood, all
kinds of stuff. No indoor plumbing, no
electricity, no hospitals, no no
clinics, no doctors, no pharmacies, no
pharmacists, no pharmaceuticals, no
drugs, no social security, no insurance,
no Blue Cross Blue Shield, no HMOs. I
mean, they got nothing you would go
there for. So, what makes them
interesting to me was when you look at
the book Rare Earths Cures, and you go
to the chapter entitled The Age Beaters,
not the egg beaters, but the age
beaters,
the people that live around Lake
Titicaca, Bolivia, Peru, and Chile, in
this area,
have more 100-year-olds per population
than anybody else in the world. One per
500. In America, we have one per 10,000.
They have 20 times the 100-year-olds we
do.
Think about that. They have nothing that
you would go there for other than long
life and happiness.
Now, this remained the same. This
remained the same since before written
history
until 3:00 in the afternoon, Monday,
September 4th, 1882. We know the exact
moment when everything changed. Monday,
September 4th, 3:00 in the afternoon,
1882, when this guy came along.
Well, 3:00 in the afternoon, Monday,
September 4th, 1882, Thomas Edison
pulled the switch and turned on the
first commercial Actually, he didn't do
it. His chief electrical technician, a
guy by the name of Jonathan Leaves,
pulled on the switch and turned on the
first commercial electric generating
plant in the world. By 1909, there was
no less than a dozen patented kitchen
electrical appliances. The first one was
a toaster, interestingly enough, then a
skillet. There were rice cookers and and
Crock-Pots and blenders and steam irons
and all kinds of electrical appliances.
By 1950, every city in every
industrialized nation had completely
given up wood as a fuel and had gone to
electricity
and propane and natural gas and liquid
paraffin and kerosene and heating oils
for heating and cooking.
Here comes the most profound question
you've ever had in your life, other than
being proposed to, ladies. How many wood
ashes are left over when you cook and
heat with electricity and propane and
liquid paraffin and natural gas? It's a
numeral that looks like this and begins
with a Z. Zero.
And there was no great gathering of
doctors. There was no great gathering of
doctors ringing their hands saying, "Oh
my gosh, what are we going to do?"
People have been using wood ashes as a
source of nutritional minerals since
before written history, and now
suddenly, in the space of of just 70
years after thousands and thousands of
years of using wood ashes and rice straw
ashes and peat moss ashes as fertilizer
and and supplements in our food as
culinary ashes and and cutting our salt
with it and a 70-year period just a
little blip on the radar is gone and
nobody said well where are we going to
get our our minerals doctors didn't do
that they just well this is exciting
electricity now we can get brighter
lights in the surgery room. There was no
congressional hearings there was no
Senate investigations I mean there was
nothing going on and now we're paying
the price now we're paying the price
because all the epidemics which we're
going to talk about here of degenerative
diseases are caused by mineral
deficiencies.
Here's another one of my favorites Ralph
Charles back in October of 1999 turned
100 and nice little newspaper write-up
on his 100th birthday and the thing that
was interesting to me was he was still
piloting commercial charter flights at
age 100 had no restrictions on his
health paper licenses didn't have
Alzheimer's disease didn't have macular
degeneration no cataracts does he look
like that recipe of 100 year old no he
looks like he's in his 80s to me he
looks 20 years younger than his age.
And so these are things we know we can
fly airplanes at 100 we can hit a hole
in one at 101 if we follow the right
recipe.
I'll show you two more here and then
we'll get on with the meat of this thing
this gal here Connie Douglas Reeves back
in September of 2002 turned 101 and the
day that she turned 101 they inducted
her into the Cowgirl Hall of Fame cuz
she had taught 30,000 young women how to
ride Western saddle and how to barrel
race I mean she's a legend in Texas. And
then inaugurated her inducted her into
the Cowgirl Hall of Fame now to me she
looks like one of those mean feisty
rebellious patients she's got her thumbs
in her belt her shoulders are back her
chin is up you guys imagine her doctor
saying to her Connie I need you to give
up salt now you're 101 I I got to worry
about your blood pressure
Connie I really need you to give up eggs
and red meat and chicken skin and and
dairy products and go to a margarine and
boneless skinless chicken breast and I
want you to eat tofu instead of red meat
and and I need you to in fact use egg
beaters instead of eggs and use
margarine instead of butter.
And Connie's going to ponder for a
minute then say
Doc I've been using salt and eating
butter and red meat and eggs and chicken
skin before you're born I ain't going to
give them up now. Let's give her A WHOA
OKAY this is kind OF A CUTE ONE THESE
GUYS are in the Guinness World Book of
Records a year ago May of 2005 Percy and
Florence Arrowsmith in Hereford England
and they were put in the Guinness World
Book of Records not because of their age
but because they've been married to each
other for 80 years and the Guinness Book
of World Records asked them what their
secret was she said she drank a glass of
red wine for breakfast and had a shot of
whiskey before bed.
And he said well I guess I can render it
down to two words and then what they
whipped out their pens and they were
ready for this profound two words and
they said well what is it? And he said
yes ma'am this little gal here Elizabeth
Israel from the Caribbean island of
Dominica back in January of 2001 turned
126 this is a birthday announcement not
obituary turned 126 and when she was
asked Elizabeth what do you attribute
your health and your longevity to she
said I grew up eating food grown without
chemical fertilizer. Now what do you
think her grandmother and her mother
used as fertilizer in their gardens wood
ashes you got it what are wood ashes
plant minerals that are left when you
burn away the carbon in the wood amen.
Whoa changing pace here a little bit in
April of 1990 the World Health Center
and the the Center for Disease Control
did a survey in the top 32
industrialized nations they said out of
the top 32 industrialized nations the
United States ranked 17th in the world
in health and longevity now we spend
more money for health care than all the
other nations in the world put together
there's 92 nations we spend more money
for health care than the other 91 and
yet in April of 1990 we ranked 17th. And
Japan was number one let's give them a
whoa for being number one whoa 79.1 we
were 75 well 10 years later when they
redid the study
Japan maintained number one at 74.5 but
they had dropped five years 4. something
years they dropped but they still
maintained number one but America
dropped from 17th to 24th cuz we went
from 75 to 70 in that 10 year period
from April of 1990 to June of 2000 well
five years later in August of 2005 the
World Health Organization Center for
Disease Control did another survey and
they published this in Newsweek
magazine. I love this special edition
summer of 2005 was on the stands until
August 2005 the future of medicine your
health in 21st century and they talked
about new treatments these are
theoretical treatments not existing ones
for cancer Alzheimer's diabetes you know
they wanted more money for donations and
then in the article number one at page
10 there's this wonderful little
paragraph that said America has built
the world's highest high-tech medicine
system in the world I don't think we can
argue with that surgeons don't even do
surgery anymore robots do it just like
car assembly plants robots do most of
the bone surgery now cuz they make so
many mistakes in hip replacement
shoulder replacement surgery they
anesthetize you and then they put you
under this robot and the robot cuts your
bone off and sticks the the new joint in
there and the robot does it all now cuz
it's much more accurate than a human
being the doctor's in the back room
drinking beer and sucking on a cigarette
while the robot's doing the surgery
the sentence goes on to say and yet the
nation meaning America now ranks 46th in
longevity now there's 45 other countries
whose people live longer than us well
last year in 2005 the entire world spent
2.7 trillion dollars for health care now
that 2.7 trillion dollars the world
spent we alone spent 1.9 trillion more
than 2/3 and we ranked 46th in the world
our health care system sucks would be a
kind way of putting it you're not
getting the bang for the buck and you
not a single one of you in this room
would put up with that in any other
industry you would not put up with this
in any other industry it's time for us
to be the Home Depot of health care
people are looking for it.
And then even worse it goes on and says
in 41 other countries including Cuba for
God's sakes have achieved lower rates of
infant mortality they have a higher rate
of baby surviving the first year and
being born alive than we do Cuba.
Think about that a poor
non-industrialized communist nation does
a better job of live births and first
year survivability for babies than us.
Whose fault is that well it's the
medical system's fault it's the medical
doctor's fault it's the pediatrician's
fault it's the OBGYN's fault. Now
there's things we can do immediately
they're going to be fun and you'll love
to do them and you will do them you'll
start tonight I guarantee you it's just
so easy there's some things you won't
like to change and you're going to drag
your toes and say well doc isn't there
anything else I could chat I don't want
to give that one up so I'm going to show
you one of each and you'll get kind of a
clue this is out of the British Medical
Journal which is the equivalent of the
Journal of the American Medical
Association this was December 23rd 1997
and it was a big study a big huge study
on more than a thousand men between the
ages of 45 and 59 remember this is the
British Medical Journal this is not a
comic book or newspaper even.
They said frequent sex helps men live
longer.
Those men who had sex twice a week live
50% longer than those who have sex only
once a month.
So ladies if you have a keeper
well that's a keeper if the guy you want
to keep you know how to keep him if you
have a dumpster
you want to drop kick that sucker
someplace without going to jail
you know how to accomplish it right?
Well this study came out the same month
December 4th though a couple of weeks
early the sex one 1997 this was a study
it was actually uh started in 1990 but
they didn't report it until 1997 what
they did was look at the longevity of
people county by county in the United
States I mean they went county by county
and calculated the longevity and they
did a color coding the people who are
the longest lived people in America in
the upper Midwest in the plain states
we're talking about Eastern Montana
North and South Dakota Minnesota
Wisconsin Iowa Northern Missouri Eastern
Nebraska and Kansas these are the
longest lived people in America in the
upper Midwest in the plain states the
shortest lived people in America come
from the southeast part of the United
States the old South if you will from
Chesapeake Bay down to Central Texas and
you can just see the classic demarcation
the people in the upper Midwest in the
plain states are in blue and dark purple
and the ones in the old South are in
yellow orange and red there's a very
distinct demarcation and this in the old
South is called the heart attack stroke
and cancer belt of America how many of
you've ever heard that phrase before
yeah in the southeast part of the United
States this is a cancer heart attack and
stroke belt of America the people in the
upper Midwest in the plain states live
20 years longer than the people in the
South. 20 years longer have the same
insurance they have the same medications
the same idiot doctors the same
hospitals
got the same and yet the people in the
upper Midwest in the plain states live
20 years longer.
What's the difference well the people in
the upper Midwest in the plain states
primarily there's exceptions of course
but primarily at least historically and
culturally in those areas they cook
everything by roasting and stewing how
do people cook in the old South frying
there is fried potatoes and fried fish
and fried chicken and chicken fried
steak and fried green tomatoes and fried
okra and fried hushpuppies I mean it's
been alleged that people in the old
South even fry water.
And because of the free radicals and the
trans fatty acids that are created by
frying
the rate of cancer and heart attack and
stroke is higher.
And so if you do nothing else but never
again after leaving this convention
never again ever ever ever put a french
fry or anything fried in your mouth you
will add 20 healthy years to your life.
And you'll save a lot of money and
cleaning up your home it's a lot easier
to clean up your home when you have stew
as opposed to frying
so you're going to save a lot of money
and you'll add 20 healthy years to your
life if you never again eat anything
fried goodbye churches goodbye Popeye
goodbye french fry I mean I can go into
McDonald's and have a nice sandwich and
a salad now I don't eat the french fries
I don't I don't drink the soft drinks.
You you can go to McDonald's have a nice
meal but you don't want to eat the fried
stuff that that's where the dangerous
part you know my tape dead doctors don't
lie doctors were always angry with me
because they said doctors only live to
be 58 so they redid their own study and
to make a long story short they came out
five years later in all the medical
journals they said well Alec Clyde
he lied he wasn't right doctors don't
live to be 58 like Wallach said they
live to be 56.
I missed it by two years.
So they don't bother me on that one
anymore.
They were obligated to publish it
because somebody had donated the money
for the study.
So, why do we listen to a group of
people whose average lifespan is 56 on
longevity?
Whoa, that's not very bright. What do
doctors die from? Diabetes, heart
disease, stroke, cancer. Hello.
My favorite doctor obituaries are the
fitness doctors, the sports medicine
doctors who died at 38 while jogging. I
love the ones who are cardiologists.
They're the They teach cardiology at
Harvard Medical School and died 48 of a
heart attack. What Why do we listen to
those people? Oh, they're they're
doctors.
Well, there's general contractors who
have licenses from the state to to build
buildings and bridges and roads. Yet,
people still go to Home Depot and paint
their own house and retile their own
house and fix a loose board in a porch.
It's time, folks. The people still go to
doctors cuz they don't know that there
is options available. Who's going to
tell them there's options? We are.
Okay.
I love this. US News & World Report,
January-February 2005, a little over a
year ago. This isn't me, guys. This is
US News & World Report. Who needs
doctors? Your future physician might not
be an MD and you may be better off.
Cover article, US News & World Report
last week and I apologize for not having
the slide. How many of you saw the the
Time magazine for last week? The cover
has a picture of a medical doctor in his
white coat with a little doctor pin on
and stethoscope laying in a hospital bed
with scalpels and and tweezers and tongs
and all kinds of things coming at him
and he's in terror.
The one thing that doctors are afraid
of, going to the doctor, going to the
hospital. They're terrified because they
know the statistics. Last November, we
had some great meetings up in Toronto
and I always love to read their papers
cuz when you get off the airplane, I
always get their newspapers the first
thing. They're always talking about the
medical system. The doctors, you know
him. To mark its 30th anniversary, the
US magazine entitled Foreign Policy, one
of these political foreign policy
magazines comes out monthly. Been around
for a long time. Asked a group of think
tank people universities to study and
identify which ideas, values, and
institutions will disappear in the next
35 years. Guess which is number one.
Guess which one's going to disappear for
sure for sure in 35 years. Medical
doctors.
Now, there's always going to be heart
transplant surgeons. There's always
going to be orthopedic surgeons. But,
it's the primary care physician, the
family doctor is gone within 35 years.
Who's going to take their place? We are.
Because we can deliver.
We can deliver.
And of course, we know because we're
ranked 46th in the world now in health
and longevity, they flunked.
Doctors lie to get insurers to pay. They
send in bills for things they didn't do.
They come to Vegas, they lose $10,000,
go home Sunday night, Monday morning
they put in a bill to the insurance
company on your insurance numbers. They
pay $10,000, he can pay his mortgage,
his car payments, and everything. He
doesn't lose a lick. You try to do that,
they put you in jail for insurance
fraud. They don't go to jail.
Doctors, according to Harvard Medical
School, 52% of medical doctors, licensed
medical doctors, 52% of licensed medical
doctors are on drugs or intoxicated with
alcohol at any one time. So, if you see
two doctors in one day, you don't know
which one was drunk.
You don't know which one was on drugs.
What you want to do is look at the
pupils of their eyes instead of their
degrees on the wall.
You want to see if they're really wound
out on something. And because they're
wound out on drugs, 52% of them at any
one time. This is a Harvard study. This
isn't me.
They make a lot of mistakes. They can't
even tell if you're alive or dead.
And especially when organs are in great
demand for transplants, they might not
want to know if you're alive or dead.
So, you don't want to check that little
box on your driver's license. Study
finds that doctors skip key steps of
treatments, 50%. They don't do 50% of
the things they're supposed to do for
you for simple things like high blood
pressure and diabetes. They get paid for
the full thing. What would you do if you
go to a automobile dealership and you
pay for 20 things to be done for your
car, you're down the street and you look
at it and say, "Wait a minute, I paid
for 20 things but they only marked 10."
You turn around, you go back and say,
"Did you make a mistake here?" "Oh, no,
no, things are so costly and we figured
you only wanted to pay so much, so we
took that money but we only gave you
half of what you paid for. You'd be
kicking the counter, you want to see the
manager, you want your money back,
you're going to call the state attorney
general, "I'm coming back with my
lawyer." But, let a doctor do that to
you. Well, he's a doctor. According to
Harvard Medical School, not me, November
1996, examining the casualty count. If
you look up the word casualties in the
Webster's dictionary, it says military
killed and injured in battles. Why would
they use a term like that for hospital
deaths? Hmm. The annual toll of medical
harm in US hospitals, one year, 1.3
million physical injury and 180,000
killed.
Three years later, November 1999,
medical mistakes were the eighth top
killer of Americans behind
cardiovascular disease, cancer,
diabetes, Alzheimer's disease,
gastrointestinal problems, liver
problems, kidney problems, and doctors.
But, they did improve. You got to give
them credit, they did improve. Three
years later, December 2002, doctors were
no longer the eighth top killer of
Americans, they moved up to number
three.
Because they went from 180,000 killed
each year in the hospitals to 250,000
killed. This is a study by Johns Hopkins
School of Public Health and Hygiene,
which is a department of the medical
school. Now, we're number one.
Yeah, we're actually number one cuz they
kill 728,000
every year.
Remember, we're now ranked 46th in the
world in longevity?
2 million Americans are infected each
year in hospitals at the hands of
doctors, 2 million, cuz they don't wash
their little hands. They just don't wash
their hands, they're busy. You know,
they take a pee in front of a toilet.
You flush that toilet, there's an
aerosol, it gets all over their white
coat, their tie, their their shirt,
their little clipboard they're carrying,
their hands. They don't wash their
hands, there's a long line there. I got
to see a patient. They run to see you.
They walk at you and they want to look
at your eyelids.
And so, when they start walking at you
either in their clinic or your hospital
room and and you see them pass the
basin, they don't wash their hands, you
want to stop them. Back off.
Don't even come near me. How many people
did you kill last month, you know?
Hold their feet to the fire. And despite
heroic round-the-clock nursing care and
intravenous antibiotics, 100,000 of
these people die. Each year in America,
2.2 million untoward or bad drug
reactions,
which means about 40 life-threatening
drug errors each day
in hospitals, in every hospital. 2.2
million and despite heroic care, 140,000
to 200,000 die. Now, I don't know how
quick you are with numbers, but I'll
give you the tally. That turns out to be
5.8 million casualties inflicted on the
American public each year in the
doctor's workplace, the hospital. 5.8
million casualties each year in America
killed, injured, and infected in the
doctor's workplace and they've never had
an OSHA ticket written against them. You
would not tolerate that. Oh, But, you
mean you know those terrible mine
explosions in West Virginia where 14 men
got killed. What It was a tragedy. But,
I mean, there's the safety board,
there's OSHAs in there, the mine
inspectors,
Senate investigations, House of
Representatives studies, and all this
stuff going on. Those mines may never
open again.
And here's one trade in their workplace
inflict 5.8 million casualties every
year in their customers and nobody could
give a stuff.
Well, who's going to save them? We are.
Whoa. It's up to us, folks, because if
you're expecting doctors to say, "Well,
we've been wrong all these years and
we're going to start using vitamins and
minerals now and we're not going to do
that nasty nasty dangerous surgery
anymore. We're not going to use drugs,
we're just going to use herbs." Now, if
you think doctors are going to do that,
you're living in la-la land.
People always tell me that, "Well,
doctors are coming around. I saw a
doctor on Sanjay Gupta on
Fox News said that there's a good herb
out there." Well, that doesn't translate
to doctors doing anything.
That's me when I was 18 years old.
Didn't have a grandma fat tummy. I did
have a flat tummy at one time in my
life.
Captain of the wrestling team on the
weightlifting team. I actually played
middle linebacker on the football team
when I only weighed 127 lb, but I made
up the lack of weight in meanness.
Exercise without supplementation is
suicide.
What do all athletes do regardless of
sports? They sweat. And if you're
sweating and you're not replacing all
that soup of nutrients that are coming
out in your sweat, you're doomed to
either break down like Theo did. Thank
God he didn't die.
But, he broke down physically because
all the nutrients required to maintain
repair his cartilage and ligaments and
tendons, connective tissue and bone and
and muscle weren't there and so he broke
down under the stress of all this
high-performance activity. You give all
this stuff back, he kind of regrew
everything. Isn't that amazing? What a
concept. Exercise without
supplementation is suicide. Many of you
remember the Gordeeva-Grinkovs, really
good-looking couple, Russian couple.
They were the darlings of the pairs
figure skating world. He died of
cardiomyopathy heart disease at age 28.
Won four gold medals, two in the
Olympics and two in the World Games. Had
everything going for him. Money, fame,
bam, 28 dies. Cardiomyopathy heart
attack. What's that caused by a
deficiency of? Selenium. Very good.
Walter Payton died of liver disease
waiting for a liver transplant. Mr.
Clean, never drank, never did drugs, was
a gentleman, but he sweat. And he just
drank water or the dark side, Gatorade.
I love this crowd.
It's really these are tragic stories.
This gal here, Rhonda Pierce, 19 years
old, great basketball player for Florida
State University, 19 years old, a
freshman, 6'5", had all the moves,
good-looking, very bright young woman.
She was expected to be kind of the
Michael Jordan of the WNBA. She was
going to be the the female version of
Michael Jordan when she graduated
college and got into the Women's
National Basketball Association. She
died of a ruptured aneurysm at 19 years
of age. What did she die from? A copper
deficiency. Exactly. All the money and
all the future and all the potential she
had went away because she was living on
Coca-Cola and french fries and no
supplementation because the sports
medical doctor at that university told
her, "You can get everything you need by
eating your basic four food groups.
French fries, Coca-Cola, fried chicken,
Reggie Lewis, had it all, captain of the
Boston Celtics. Had his first
cardiomyopathy heart attack, 28 years
old, collapsed. They gathered together
12 of the best cardiologists in the
world. They called them the dream team
of cardiology, paid get a million
dollars each to refer all their patients
out to other doctors so they could
devote full time to Reggie. They wanted
him back on the floor.
He was a powerhouse. He was a leader. He
made things happen. And he was kind of
like the Theo Ratliff of those days. And
what a great kid he was. Clean as you
could be. A great example for everybody.
But while they were arguing who was
going to get famous by doing the heart
transplant or installing a pacemaker, he
dies of his second cardiomyopathy heart
attack 2 weeks later. Well, God has a
great way of bringing justice to the
evil. A year and a half later, the
captain of the dream team of
cardiologists,
one Dr. W. Thomas Nessa, taught
cardiology at Harvard, ran the Boston
Marathon every year, was as fit as you
could be, a person who believed in
fitness and so was a fitness nut
himself, dies of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack in his home at age 48.
Now, if he was my cardiologist, and he
said exercise without supplementation
was good, I would lay on the couch, I
would never blink, I would not do
anything that resembled physical
activity.
If he said salt was bad, I would take
top off the salt shaker and I'd be
guzzling that stuff.
If he said eggs were bad because of the
cholesterol, I'd be eating 25 a day.
Cuz I wouldn't want to wind up like him.
Even though he was an expert, he's a
dead expert.
And they don't lie. They don't lie.
Wilma Rudolph, another Olympic legend,
died of brain cancer at age 54 after
winning three gold medals in a single
Olympics in the 19 Was it 1960 Olympics?
She died of brain cancer.
Nope, not arsenic. Nope. Gallium. I can
tell who's reading the book, Rare Earths
Forbidden Cures, chapter 11, under G,
gallium. It's a gallium deficiency. Big
British study. I cite the study. No
doubt about it. Korey Stringer, 350-lb
offensive tackle for the Minnesota
Vikings, had it all, rich
athlete, but they wanted him to lose 50
lbs so he could play first string that
year.
They put him in a rubber suit, didn't
give him any water, and didn't give him
any salt. 102°
Minnesota in the summer in August, and
he collapses with heatstroke. Everybody
has a cell phone, 911, here comes the
ambulance 5 or 10 minutes later they
arrive. Now, Korey weighs 350 lbs, and
they hook him up with an IV. Boy, they
got the EMTs, they hook him up to an IV.
Is that enough fluid for him? No. What
they should have done was taken that big
Gatorade bucket full of ice,
put it on him. They should have ripped
his trousers off and stuck the hose from
the garden up his rump and give him a
cold water enema, bring his core
temperature down from 107 to 98.6, and
Korey Stringer would still be alive
today. But everybody's waiting for the
doctors to do it. Now, if there'd have
been an Eagle Scout there, he'd have
lived.
All poor Korey had was the top sports
medicine doctors.
Gatorade only has two nutrients, sodium
and potassium, both of which are useful,
but it's only two. What about the other
58 minerals? What about the gallium?
What about the selenium? What about the
zinc? What about the copper? Zero zero
zero zero.
People say, "Well, it's not convenient."
Well, then die.
Yeah, death is a very inconvenient
thing.
Time magazine. If you want to know
what's going on in health, read Time and
Newsweek magazine. December 2004, a
little over a year ago,
big article on high blood pressure, the
stealth killer. "America's high blood
pressure crisis is spinning out of
control." How can we have a high blood
pressure crisis? We've got calcium
channel blockers, we've got beta
blockers, we've got all these diuretics,
and we have exercise and fitness
systems, more people involved with that
than ever before. People are losing
weight, you know, the obesity problem's
hopefully getting under control. We're
doing everything the doctors say, and
it's spinning out of control.
That's because you cannot fix a mineral
deficiency problem with surgery and
drugs. Amen.
What's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his livestock out in the
pasture? A salt block or a salt lick,
isn't it? There's nobody out in the
pasture telling a cow she's limited to
one lick a day, is there?
No, I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow or a goat
or something like that. And so I say,
"You go ahead and salt your food to
taste." Well, how do I know if it's too
much? Well, it'll taste salty if it's
as high-tech as I can get.
July 1997,
July 1997, just about 9 years ago now, a
presentation at the American Heart
Association's annual meeting in
Portland, Oregon. Doctors lack proof
that too much salt is unhealthful. "If
you're telling healthy people that too
much salt isn't good for them,
researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up that claim."
The same study, it was called the Sodium
Task Force, just a different newspaper,
they kind of came at it a little
different direction. They said the
study, the Sodium Task Force found that
people who limited their salt intake to
1,000 mg or 1 g a day like their doctors
wanted them to do, had 600% more or six
times more heart attacks than those who
defied their doctors and consumed more
than double. If you followed your
doctor's instructions, you're not going
to make it.
So says September 2000 Scientific
American. Remember that?
If you take your your diuretics, it's
only going to get rid of more minerals.
Scientific American, February 1999,
they went to Nigeria, out in the bush
where people had never seen a doctor in
a white coat, they'd never seen a
stethoscope, they'd never heard of
diuretics or calcium channel blockers,
and they started taking blood pressures
and they found that 7% of these people
living out in the very primitive
circumstances out in the bush, 7% had
high blood pressure. They came back to
Chicago, did a lot of DNA testing, found
a lot of people whose ancestors had
originated in Nigeria during the old
slave trade days in the 16, 1700s, and
they started taking their blood
pressure, and 33% of them had high blood
pressure. They knew immediately, without
doing another single one penny's worth
of research, that it is not genetic.
Because if it was genetic, it'd be 7% 7%
or 33% 33% because where you are in the
world will not change how genetics
expresses itself. If you have a genetic
problem in Nigeria, you're going to have
the same genetic problem in Bolivia. If
you have that same genetic problem in
Bolivia, you're going to have the same
genetic problem in New York. It doesn't
matter where you are on Earth, if you
have a genetic problem, you have a
genetic problem. So you know
immediately, fourth grade biology is not
genetic. So what's the difference here?
Well, the people in Nigeria out in the
bush are still putting their wood ashes,
their plant minerals into their food.
They're still fertilizing their garden
with it. They still use wood as a fuel.
The guys in Chicago are living on
diuretics and calcium channel blockers
and statin drugs to lower cholesterol
and Church's Fried Chicken and
Pepsi-Cola and Coca-Cola Gatorade. Whoa.
Okay now, 6 years later, the British
Medical Journal. 6 years later, the
British Medical Journal. Remember guys,
the same one that said sex twice a week
will give you 50% more longevity. Whoa.
So we got to believe them, right?
High blood pressure in blacks not
genetic. This is January 2005. High
blood pressure in blacks not genetic.
High blood pressure in whites not
genetic. High blood pressure in human
beings not genetic. High blood pressure
is not genetic. You've heard me say many
times, we've eliminated 900 different
diseases in animals with those little
pellets in canned dog food with all the
vitamins and minerals in it. Well, dogs
and canaries and worms and crickets and
and monkeys and guinea pigs can all get
high blood pressure. Cows get high blood
pressure. But they don't get it when you
give them those little pellets because
we have everything in there to prevent
the high blood pressure because we don't
have insurance to pay for these drugs
and surgeries and things. How do you
tell a dog, "Well, you better sign up
for a fitness center and take, you know,
diuretics and calcium channel blocker?"
And so, if we do what we've done for our
animals, we cannot fail. We can
eliminate high blood pressure not only
in the world, we can eliminate high
blood pressure in the black community,
in the white community, in the human
community in 90 days if everybody would
take all 90 essential nutrients. Focus
on the intake of what? Calcium. And stay
away from the fried foods, stay away
from the carbonated drinks,
and watch what happens to that high
blood pressure.
I'd rather take the drugs. I just can't
give up my Popeyes.
You're going to die.
Well, do you believe it or not, how many
of you ever heard that elevated
cholesterol and triglycerides are the
basic root cause of coronary artery
disease and artery disease? Sure, we've
all heard that, right?
Well, if you can find me any disease
that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides, I'll give
you a million dollars small bills tax
free in any offshore account you want.
There's not a single disease caused by
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides. It's a signal that you
have a deficiency of niacin, vitamin B3,
a deficiency of chromium and vanadium, a
deficiency of omega-3 essential fatty
acids. You could have early
hypothyroidism or goiter. You can have
early diabetes. All those things will
cause elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides, but elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides cause no
disease.
And so that's why all these statin drugs
and all the aspirin that everybody's
been taking and all this stuff, we now
rank 46th in the world longevity doing
what doctors have told us, spending 1.9
trillion dollars a year for health care.
We rank 46th in the world. Does that
make any kind of sense? You're an MBA,
does that make any kind of sense? No.
Huh?
Bad investment? Bad investment? Come in
46th and you're spending more than all
the other 91 nations in the world put
together? Here's this little Bolivia and
they're using llama manure for fuel,
they have 20 times the 100-year-olds
than we do. Hello.
Are Are we getting a clue here?
So what causes coronary artery disease?
What causes clogged arteries? You know,
what causes it? How many of you heard of
free radicals, trans fatty acids? Yeah.
Where does it come from?
Well, look at that.
We've known this for 50 years, but
doctors say, "Oh, you got to give up
that dairy products and butter and
animal fats, and you got to go to to
margarine and cooking oils." Well, they
live to be 56, why do you believe them?
They die of heart attacks and strokes,
why would you believe them? I want you
to think of your grandparents, your moms
and dads, your aunts and uncles. How
many of you had a mom or dad or aunt or
uncle or grandparents who lived to be in
their 80s and 90s? Raise your hand.
Yeah. How many of you had any of them
live to be in the hundreds? Hundred.
Yeah, there's a handful in here. And I
guarantee you they ate four to six eggs
for breakfast. They ate butter instead
of mar- They didn't have margarine back
in those days. They ate butter, they
cooked in lard.
They ate their chicken skin. Can you
imagine any- You can imagine my
grandfather tearing the chicken skin off
the chicken
before he ate it? using anything else
but real butter,
eating tofu
on a beef farm.
Hello.
So, it's the free radical damage to the
lining of the arteries that causes
coronary artery disease. Well, you get
rid of the free radicals in your life.
Why is that called the heart attack
stroke and cancer belt of America in the
old South? Fried foods.
Gosh, this is so easy.
Give up the fried foods, you take in all
your antioxidants, selenium, OPC.
Very easy.
I'm 66 years old. My blood pressure is
121 over 71. My resting pulse is 47. If
I were to go to a doctor for a physical
now, they would have a hemorrhage.
They'd send me in for a pacemaker. What?
Your resting pulse is 47? You you're
going to have a heart attack. Really?
Well, let's see who can lift the most
weight and keep alive here, doc.
Also, low cholesterol makes you stupid.
I love that study.
Well, they took almost 800 men and 1,100
women. They divided them into two
groups. Those with blood cholesterols
below 200, which they thought were going
to be the healthiest and smartest, and
those with blood cholesterols above 240.
And the ones who had blood cholesterols
above 240 were 49% smarter than ones
that blood cholesterols below 200.
Whoa.
Low-fat diets lose their luster for
heart attack, stroke, breast cancer,
colon cancer. There's no difference in
the rate between a low-fat diet and
high-fat diet. No difference whatsoever.
Obesity is now it was on television
again this morning as the number one
preventable killer. There's 16% of
American kids who are obese.
By the year 2010,
they say that 75% of Americans will be
overweight and 40% will be obese. Now,
this is despite all these surgeries,
beside all the drugs. Uh there's more
people involved with fitness than ever
before. That's because we're living on
too much carbohydrates and not enough
people are taking in nutrients,
especially minerals. Sweet fruit drinks
make pudgy kids fatter.
Fruit juice fruit juice. I'm not giving
my kid Pepsi, I'm giving him apple
juice. We're living on dry cereals and
apple juice. They go to school with a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich. They
come home and eat Kraft's macaroni and
cheese and the parents think they're
giving them a good diet.
There's nothing but carbohydrates and
sugar.
There's not even anything green and
leafy or tomatoes in there. Nothing.
Nothing but sugar and carbohydrates. No
vitamins and minerals. And the kids, you
know, got ADD and ADHD and and you know
he's going to be a serial killer when he
grows up.
Well, this is the cause of obesity in
America. We don't have a lot of time, so
I'm going to tell you you can see where
the horses have chewed that rail in that
wagon out. This is called pica. You've
all read about pica or cribbing. The
only thing that will cause this behavior
where they eat dirt or chew on the fence
or wooden implements and things like
that is a mineral deficiency. Some
minerals are worse than others, but all
mineral deficiencies cause this behavior
in animals, pica cribbing where they eat
other things other than food. And it's
not boredom, it's their mineral
deficient. Pregnant women are legendary
for getting cravings during pregnancy.
Why is that? Because the baby as it's
developing is stealing minerals from the
mother. If she's not taking in enough to
counteract that, they crave things. In
the old South where they have the heart
attack stroke and cancer belt of
America, they'd cornstarch. How many of
you heard of women eating cornstarch
when they're pregnant? Yeah. And what
about clay? They go out in the yard and
eat clay when they're pregnant. People
come and say, "Doc, am I sick and am I
crazy? I I have this craving for clay."
No, you're just pregnant, my dear.
It's so common in the old South. You go
to a grocery store in the dairy section,
they got these little bags of yellow
clay, red clay, orange clay, blue clay,
black clay. You can have your choice.
Whichever one flips your switch.
I love this one. Came out in October of
last year. Eating dirt may be good for
you. Don't take vitamins and minerals,
you can overdose, but eat dirt.
Experts claim the habit of eating clay
may be beneficial for pregnant women.
Now, what is in clay? Clay is minerals.
And the woman says, "The real good stuff
is smooth. Tastes just like candy."
The habit of eating clay or dirt is
known as geophagy. Geo for earth and
phagy for eat. Some experts lump it into
the same category as pica, which is the
abnormal urge to eat coins, paint, soap,
and other non-food items such as wood
ashes.
Plant minerals. And so, there was a
natural drive for pregnant women at the
dawn of history to eat wood ashes and
dirt and clay and things looking for
minerals as those babies drove them to
be mineral deficient. I could say a lot
of things about a lot of diseases, but
I'm going to just go to selenium when it
comes to cancer because Dr. Wallach did
such an eloquent job. You've all heard
my tape. I hope you've all heard the
tape Dead Doctors Don't Lie. And on
there, I was reading this and of course
doctors turned me over to every agency
in the world because I had found an
anti-cancer diet. I was just reading
this and of course when I made that
tape, I was just reading an anti-cancer
diet has been found. They interpreted
that I was claiming that I had made an
anti-cancer diet. And what they did was
look at these vitamins and minerals. And
dietary supplements such as vitamin C,
retinol, which is a form of vitamin A,
zinc, riboflavin, vitamin B2, and
molybdenum, which is a trace mineral,
niacin B3 had no statistically
significant effect on cancer deaths over
the 5 years. Well, it takes a little bit
longer for them to do things. However,
in a group of middle-aged people, I
think there was 29,000 people between
the age of 49 and 60. During the same
5-year period, those who took only
beta-carotene, vitamin E, and the trace
mineral selenium for 5 years, results
were striking. 13% fewer deaths from all
cancers, 28% reduction deaths from
stomach cancer, which is very high in
that portion of China, and a 9%
disappearance of deaths from all causes.
Just by taking those three supplements.
And of course, they were very low doses.
They were just a portion of the RDA.
Well, in 1912, 1912 in Popular
Mechanics, that wonderful medical
journal written so you can understand
it,
Dr. Wasserman, who invented the
Wasserman test, which is that blood test
a lot of us old guys had to take before
you got married to get a license,
detected syphilis. Here had an active
case of syphilis.
Whoa. He had discovered a chemical
substance, which turned out to be
selenium, that will cure cancer in mice.
He went on to say that selenium has a
selective action against cancer cells,
but didn't hurt healthy tissues. He went
on to say that cancer in mice is so
similar to that in humans. He believed
that an important advance had been made
toward the cure that veritable scourge
cancer in people. Well, in 1912 when
this came out, we began to put selenium
into animal foods. It stayed dormant
in interest to medical doctors until
December of 1996, 84 years later,
when this came out, Dr. Larry Clark, a
medical doctor, I have to give him
credit, medical doctor, PhD from the
University of Arizona, and he did the
gold standard medical research. He did a
randomized double-blind study on 1,300
people for 7 years. Half of them got 200
micrograms or 1/5 of a milligram of
selenium, the other half got sugar pills
or placebos. And to make a long story
short, his final analysis showed taking
selenium slashed the occurrence, not the
risk, but slashed the actual occurrence,
which is much more powerful than
slashing the risk. Slashed the
occurrence of prostate cancer by 69%,
colorectal cancer by 64%, and lung
cancer by 39%. Well,
2 months after this wonderful news came
out, Dr. Larry Clark, MD PhD, dies of
prostate cancer at age 52.
He didn't take selenium because he
didn't believe in it. He actually
purposely avoided selenium because he
believed in chemotherapy because that's
how he made his living.
And so, it cost him his life. He didn't
even make it to 56, died at 52 of
prostate cancer. Nobody should die of
prostate cancer. No link found between
fat and breast cancer. High-fiber diets
don't protect you. Multivitamins cut
colon cancer risk. 90,000 nurses,
Harvard Nurses' Health Study.
15 years on a multivitamin
reduced the risk of colon cancer by 75%
in these 90,000 women. Reduced the risk
of colon cancer by 75% for like $2 a
day.
Are there any drugs that will reduce the
risk of colon cancer by 1%? No. Here's a
little nutritional formula. Will reduce
your risk of colon cancer by 75%.
It's going to cost you half of what it
cost for an espresso latte from
Starbucks. And people say, "I don't
know.
I can't remember to do that in the
morning." Well, then die.
Whoa.
And so, fortunately, there's always a
small group of people who will survive.
Just like in Katrina, there was a group
of people who when they got the word on
Thursday that it was coming and the
storm filled the entire Gulf of Mexico,
or as they say in Texas, the entire guff
of Mexico.
They they little old people little bags
of water. They start walking west. 3
days later when it hit, they were 100
miles away.
And the ones who stayed,
"The government will save us.
FEMA will do it.
Don't forget the bird flu."
Okay, I think I get diabetes and
arthritis in the last 10 minutes I have
here.
There's a diabetes epidemic. There's a
million new cases in 2000 and last year
in 2005, there was 1.6 million new
cases. It went up more than 50% in 4
years.
Went up more than 50% in 4 years.
Despite all this wondrous medical care,
and that's why we now rank 46th
in the world in health and longevity.
And so, all the insulin and all the
exercise programs and all the
amputations and all the blindness and
all the stuff we go through it it is
unnecessary.
We can eliminate high blood pressure
and diabetes in the black community, the
white community, the human community in
90 days if everybody would do the right
thing. And so,
we have loved ones. We have family. We
have churchmates. We have workmates. We
have neighbors. We we have to help them.
All will not listen.
I used to get all for I must be doing
something wrong.
I should be able to get people to
realize how important this is. And then
I think back to Jesus.
Did everybody believe Jesus? And the
answer is no. Did everybody follow his
word? No. And so, who am I to think that
I should get 100%? And so, I said,
"Okay."
And so, you have to realize and don't
take it personal
when 85% of the people say, "No, no,
I've got a good doctor.
No, no, my my blood sugar's under
control. It's 140 every morning.
I I got my cholesterol under control.
I'm taking those
statin drugs." Yeah. Yeah.
Everything's fine. I'm healthy.
Diabetes rates soar for Americans in
their 30s. Used to be called adult-onset
type 2 diabetes cuz it only occurred in
people over age 50. Well, now newborn
babies are having it. Minority kids have
the worst risk.
You take the white kids out of the
ratios, it's not 16% of the kids that
have obesity and diabetes. Guess what?
It's 50% of the kids. Okay? It's the
Hispanics, the Native Americans, the
black community.
And that's because it's not genetic,
it's because of how they eat.
Heavy kids getting grown-up diseases.
Scary diagnosis. I remember talking This
kid here is only 12 years old. He
weighed 328 lb.
High blood pressure, clogged arteries,
diabetes showing up in babies.
Is that because it's genetic? No, it's
because they're eating fried foods.
They're living on soft drinks and
Pop-Tarts and Pillsbury Toaster Strudels
and apple juice. My fear is everybody in
America is going to eat dry cereal and
and apple juice for breakfast. They have
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for
lunch. And they come home and they eat
Kraft macaroni and cheese. And they
think they're getting good food. And we
wonder why they're obese. We wonder why
they have diabetes. We wonder why they
have growing pains. We wonder why they
have ADD. Wonder why they have thyroid
problems. We wonder why they have
clogged arteries. The doctor said,
"Well, it's genetic. Your
great-great-grandfather's dog had it.
So, therefore, as you know, as
I knew it was in your family."
This is a big study. 91,000 nurses, 8
years. The Harvard Nurses Health Study.
This came out in June of 2004.
The women in the study who drank at
least one sugar-sweetened soda, didn't
matter if it was classic Coke,
Pepsi-Cola, Mountain Dew, Sprite, 7 Up,
um ginger ale, natural, organic
carbonated drinks, didn't matter.
Pellegrino water, Perrier water, if it's
carbonated, club soda, doesn't matter.
85 You're 85% more likely to get
diabetes.
If you drink two a day, you're going to
get it. How many of you have ever seen a
teenager just drink two?
Unless it's those 42-oz gulps.
Each of which has three 12-oz Cokes in
them. There's nine teaspoons of sugar
per 12-oz drink. Now, if they're
drinking 10 a day, that's 90 teaspoons
of sugar. Put 90 teaspoons of sugar in a
mixing bowl and see what your kids are
drinking.
You got to change it, folks.
This is a page out of Rare Earth
Forbidden Cures. We just look at
chromium as one of the two trace
minerals they're missing when you have
diabetes. And then, of course, there's
23 cofactors necessary for them to work.
We learned this in 1957 that we could
prevent and cure. We could prevent and
cure
diabetes in laboratory animals, pet
animals, and farm animals in 1957 with
these two trace minerals.
We proved it in human beings 20 years
later in 1977. Did doctors use this
stuff? No. There's no money in it.
There's no money in the cure. The
money's in you're going to be on this
insulin for the rest of your life.
And so, we have to show them that there
is an option.
Well, they went back the same people who
discovered this in 1957 went back to
1948. And they just looked at chromium.
1948, the amount of chromium in American
blood was a big range, 28 to 1,000 parts
per billion. In '71, it dropped to 13.
'72, it dropped to 10. '73, it dropped
to 4.7 to 5.1. In '74, it dropped to
0.73 to 1.6. In '78, it dropped to 0.16.
In '80, it popped up almost three times,
0.43. That's because in 1977, they came
out and said, "You can prevent and cure
diabetes with these trace minerals."
University of Vancouver, British
Columbia said you could re- replace
insulin with these trace minerals. They
came out big headlines and said it. And
everybody went into the health food
store and they tried it. And so,
everybody's level of of chromium in
their blood went up for a couple of
years. And then it dropped back down in
1985 to 0.13 because it wouldn't work.
Well, why won't the chromium vanadium by
themselves work? Because they need 23
cofactors. You ever hear me say take
chromium vanadium? No. You take the 90
essential nutrients cuz they're hooked
together like a web.
Who are?
Arthritis. 85% of all Americans over the
age of 50 already have arthritis and
osteoporosis of one time or another to
one degree or another. There's not a
single medical treatment. That's
according to the Center for Disease
Control, out of Atlanta, Georgia, not
me. And there's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or cure
osteoporosis or arthritis.
There's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or cure. The only
approach that the medical system has is
pain relief and surgery. Pain relief and
surgery. We eliminated arthritis and
osteoporosis in animals 300 years ago in
Europe and 1,000 years ago in China.
We've known for 1,000 years how to
prevent and cure osteoporosis and and
arthritis.
I'll give you a little hint. People hear
me say that all the time. Well, that
can't be. How many of you heard of in
the old herbal days, in the old
homeopathic days, you know, hundreds of
years ago in in China, thousands of
years ago, there's a term when they
didn't know what to use, what herb to
use to treat a disease, they always
started out with like treats like.
How many of you heard that term, like
treats like? L I K E treats l I k e. So,
if you had a blood disease, you'd take
an herb that was red.
If you had a brain disease, you ate
walnuts cuz a walnut looked like a
brain. You know, half a walnut looks
like a brain. And so, that's called the
the theory of signatures, the rule of
signatures, meaning you you take an herb
or something that looks like the part of
the body that you want to fix. And then,
it's a place as a starting point. And
sometimes it's a great treatment,
sometimes it wasn't. And so, when you
had a bone problem 1,000 years ago, what
did the old root doctors and what did
the old shamans and the old voodoo
doctors do 1,000 years ago? When you had
a bone problem, what did they MAKE YOU
EAT? BONES! HOW DIFFICULT IS THIS?
HALLELUJAH.
Who are? Now, you can't do that anymore
cuz there's lead in bones. And they they
took it off the market for human use.
Now, I can remember my dad, we ate the
meat and he ate the bones.
When I got married to my dear wife, if
you read the book Dead Doctors Don't
Lie, it's a great story. I mean, we
lived off of fish and shrimp and things
that we would catch off of our boat. We
lived on a boat. We we were boat people.
And she said, "Please don't tell my
parents we're boat people."
I said, "Honey, this is a yacht." She
says, "They don't know yachts in China.
It's a boat."
But we catch fish. I would eat the the
filets and she would eat the bones. I
said, "Don't tell people you're eating
the garbage." And she just smiled at me
and said in her shy little way, "Oh,
who's getting the better deal here?"
Who are?
The coming epidemic of arthritis. I
mean, what a sick article. The coming
The bad news is research shows disease
starts attacking your joints before
middle age. Well, they start attacking
your joints in year two.
How many of you heard of growing pains?
Yeah, if you want to have fun, go to a
mall and just sit in a chair and look at
kids. Don't look up above 3 ft. Just
look at little kids. Go to a zoo and sit
on a bench and just look at kids. Don't
look at the animals. Don't look at the
people. Just look at kids.
Now, you don't see any walking kids
anymore. This mother this 25-year-old
mother has an 18-wheeler baby cart.
She's got a 6-year-old, a 4-year-old,
and a 2-year-old. And she's got a
6-month-old on her back.
And she's struggling along with this
18-wheeler baby cart.
Now, they're living on apple juice and
dry cereal, Fruit Loops for breakfast.
And they're getting peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches for lunch. And they're
getting Kraft macaroni and cheese for
dinner.
Or French toast, you know, well, white
bread and egg beaters. And these kids
can't walk 2 ft.
Pick me up. And they just sit down, you
know.
Now, if I'd have done that when I was 6
years old, my dad would bam!
He's, "I'm not carrying you, boy." He
said, "You get up and walk or you're
going to die where you lay."
Our wonderful FDA approved Vioxx.
Approved Vioxx. They never took it off
the market.
Merck took it off the market after 4
years cuz their accountant said you'll
never sell enough. You'll never sell
enough to pay for all the lawsuits.
Over the 4-year period, there was
139,000
people had heart attacks that could be
linked directly to Vioxx. 139,000
in 4 years. And depending on whose
statistics and data you look at, 55,000
or 85,000 of them died. And the FDA
never took it off the market. Aren't
they protecting us?
Oh, you can't use those vitamins and
minerals. You might overdose.
Arthroscopic surgery
for arthritis is a worthless procedure
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine. It was a big study done by the
Harvard Medical School, July 2002.
Why did doctors continue to use
arthroscopic surgery for arthritis of
the knee? $1.5 billion they made in
income in that one procedure
in in the year 2001.
Osteoporosis strikes both sexes equally.
I had to go to Canada to learn this.
November 2001, The Globe and Mail, great
Canadian newspaper. Osteoporosis strikes
both sexes equally. Anybody read that in
an American newspaper? No. Big study,
10,000 people, over 3,000 men, over
6,000 women. Men are as likely as women
to suffer from osteoporosis, a surprise
finding from a new 5-year Canadian study
to be released today, it said. The
results turn the tables on the belief
that women are the prime victims of
conditions. Now, here's kind of
interesting.
This study, the results of the study
will almost certainly change the way
that medical professionals deal with the
unexplained bone fractures in men and
the way that education about the
condition is handled. Now, raise your
hand, gentlemen, if you got an email or
a postcard or a phone call or a letter
or some kind of communication from your
personal medical doctor, your primary
care physician, your family doctor
saying, "Roy, you better come on in
because we just learned that men get
osteoporosis at equal rate with women.
Now, I want to do a bone density test on
you." Any of you men get that from your
medical doctor? Now, I've given this
lecture for 5 years now. I've lectured
300 times a year. I've been in eight
countries. And I've never had a single
man raise his hand or a married man,
either. Never had any man raise his
hand. I've realized what that sounded
like. Okay.
Now, here comes the killer. The guy
who's in charge of the Department of
Rheumatology, you know, the the bone
disease guy from McMaster University,
which is like their Harvard Medical
School.
We didn't think that men got fractures.
And now, this is what he's teaching to
medical students. You want to slap that
guy, grind him up, and feed him to a
rabid dog.
And he's teaching that to medical
doctors that men don't get fractures.
Disregard them. They're all gnarled up
with dowager's hump. They can't even
pick up a glass of water. Well, you're
okay. You're a man. You don't get
osteoporosis and arthritis.
Hua.
Carbonated drinks. Carbonated drinks.
10 years before this, in 1990, the
Harvard Nurses' Health Study looked at
90,000 nurses over a 10-year period, and
they looked at these adult nurses from
between the ages of 35 and 70, and they
discovered that those drinking non-cola
carbonated drinks had an increased risk
of fractures and osteoporosis over those
who just drank water and tea by 300%.
The ones who drank cola carbonated
drinks increased their risk of fractures
and osteoporosis over those just
drinking water or tea by 500%. So, they
wanted to see if this happened in girls,
right? They're thinking that it's a
women's disease, right? And so, they
went to Boston. They got to 460 young
girls in the 9th and 10th grade, and
they did a little study on them, and
they found out that the girls who drank
carbonated drinks were three times more
likely to get fractures and
osteoporosis. I mean, we're talking
about junior high school girls.
They have a 300% increase in the risk of
getting osteoporosis and arthritis and
fractures over girls who drink water and
tea.
Now, why would you let your kids drink
that stuff?
And want to end up
with that reminder
that if it's to be, it's up to me. If
it's to be, it's up to us.
Just don't expect everybody to believe
us.
Everybody doesn't believe Jesus. And so,
why would they believe us? And so, we
can only save thems that will be saved.
We have to keep telling the story and
telling the story. Did Jesus give up
when people rebuked him? Till his last
breath, he kept on going. He was the
only one who satisfied the law out of
the Bible. Adam couldn't even keep his
mouth shut not eat the apple.
That's all he had to do. That's all Adam
had to do is not eat the apple.
And so, we have to keep talking. We have
to keep sharing the message. That's what
this is all about. And if we do this,
you will be rewarded beyond your wildest
dreams because we are going to be the
Home Depot of health care in THE NEXT
DECADE. HUA. HUA. HUA.
Information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration and are not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
disease. Thank you for listening to this
presentation, and remember to contact
the person that sent this to you. For
more presentations and books that go
into greater detail, go to
docwallachmedia.com,
and be well.
These statements have not been evaluated
by the FDA.
These products are not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
disease.
The opinions expressed in this
informational program are the expressed
opinions of Joel D. Wallach, BS, DVM,
and ND, are not a replacement for proper
medical advice and treatment. In all
cases, we recommend you contact your
physician directly regarding any medical
conditions.